the border crossing from israel into
gaza open for the first time in six days
much needed medical supplies food and
fuel are heading across it the latter
for gaza's only power plant shut since
saturday
in ashkelon on the israeli side of the
border people have headed out for the
first time since islamic jihad and
israel declared a truce
many are relieved and triumphant
it's the first time we've entered a
ceasefire and we feel very good
after we destroyed them we can sleep
peacefully
i don't think islamic jihad will do
anything again in the next three or four
years
but some are already looking ahead to
the next round of violence
the machine
we do not trust them they promise they
promise but they always attack again
except that this time it was israel that
attacked first
launching what it termed as a
pre-emptive strike into gaza
dozens of people were killed in the
resulting escalation among them two
islamic jihad leaders
in israel there were no deaths the iron
dome defense system stopped most of the
rockets that made it across the border
on monday that was seen as a win for the
interim prime minister and defense
minister just as election season warms
up
i think it put
both guns the the the defense minister
and prime minister lapid in a good uh uh
a point
uh where they are experienced okay they
they behave they behaved well they kept
it they they kept it short and
so i think it will work in their favor
to what extent i don't know exactly
israeli officials briefing national
media seem more interested in focusing
on hamas the group that controls gaza
rather than islamic jihad and that's
because hamas this time round decided
not to join the fighting preventing an
escalation and the officials seem to
think that the ceasefire and that meant
that there was a possible way forward
perhaps to even talk about a prisoner
swap
many in gaza will be looking towards the
nearer future hoping that israel will
reopen the border to let in the 14 000
people with work permits something
israel says it's prepared to do if the
situation remains calm
john holman al jazeera west jerusalem